was passiert mit unserer Psyche wenn wir
zum Mars fliegen stellt euch vor ihr
seid monatelang in einem engen
Raumschiff eingesperrt ohne die
Möglichkeit mal eben nach draußen zu
gehen die Isolation und enge können zu
Stress Angst und sogar Depressionen
führen um diesen psychologischen
Belastungen entgegenzuwiken muss die
Auswahl und das Training der Astronauten
sorgfältig durchgeführt werden die
raumfahrtorganisationen suchen nach
Menschen die nicht nur körperlich fit
sondern auch psychisch stabil sind und
gut in Teams arbeiten können es ist
wichtig dass die Astronauten lernen mit
umzugehen ihre Emotionen zu regulieren
und effektiv mit ihren Teamkollegen zu
kommunizieren zusätzlich können
Technologien wie Virtual Reality dazu
beitragen das Gefühl der Isolation zu
reduzieren indem sie den Astronauten
erlauben virtuell in ihrer Heimat oder
andere entspannte Umgebungen
einzutauchen die Zukunft der Raumfahrt
hängt nicht nur von der Technologie ab
sondern auch von der menschlichen
Fähigkeit sich an das Leben im Weltraum
anzupassen und dabei unsere psychische
Gesundheit zu bewahren wir müssen uns
also fragen